all right thank you once again for
clicking on this video that showed my
mug in the thumbnail i do appreciate
that before we get started i do want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by noom noom is
a consumer-led digital health program
but it's more than that new muse is
human coaches psychology and science to
empower people to take control of their
health they take control of their health
through healthy eating habits exercise
and mindset i appreciate the fact that
nume operates with that concept of the
symbiotic relationship between the
mental and the physical and that's why i
jumped on a resounding yes when they
wanted to sponsor this video because for
the last if you look at the last couple
years at least for me the last couple
years have been very conducive to a
negative mindset and negative habits and
i for one i'm over it so new year better
habits positive mindset i'm on this
newman journey looking forward to where
it takes me both physically and mentally
if you want to start that journey for
yourself click the link below go to
noom.com john's get yourself a free new
evaluation and seven day trial see where
it takes you and thank you once again to
noon for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it and now we get to the
review because that's kind of what we do
here
[Music]
so the 355 is an espionage spy thriller
with a great cast but
it's that espionage
did you see a trailer for that movie
where you're like oh that looks
interesting and now you're like oh oh
the movie came out already i totally
forgot about it that's 355. it revolves
around a crew of spies or former spies
throughout the world there's this device
in terms of cyber terrorism this is a
super bad device it can manipulate shut
down it could basically do anything
to anything in the digital world i mean
when i say in terms of cyber terrorism
it's now the worst digital cyber
terrorist device ever devised for cinema
so this crew of spies generally speaking
led by jessica chastain like we don't
know who to trust we don't know if we
can trust our agencies but they do feel
like they can trust each other so
they're going to save the day and yeah
the cash in this movie legit cast
jessica chastain diane krueger lupita
nyong'o penelope cruz and this great
cast probably adds to the disappointment
of the movie the fact that the movie's
just
okay with a cast like that what i liked
about the movie there were a couple
moments in here great moments of tension
and just the acting among the actors
that really sells the tension lupita
nyong'o in particular was a standout
when it comes to that also as much as
the movie has fun with his premise and
fun with the cast and crew it's not a
comedy they don't go for laughs and
jokes feels weird to be like that's a
positive but in this day and age a lot
of movies they do go for the jokes and
it kind of takes me out of the movie
this movie didn't do that and as much as
i will say when it's going down at the
end of the movie like the end shootout
the last shootout in this movie was
actually pretty sweet would have been
better if i could see more of it because
yes this movie does that shaky
cam i shouldn't be too surprised even
the matrix does shaky cam now nothing is
safe it's not just shaky cam it's the
editing also when someone does something
as simple as picks up a gun and shoots a
few people i don't need a bunch of edits
to give me a bunch of different angles
with that just frame it up let me see
what's going on john wickett or for this
female-centric film jane wicket if you
prefer the terminology i don't care just
frame it up well i noticed that was
going to be a problem earlier on in the
movie when people are chasing people and
the camera's doing that i was like oh
god i thought we were it's 2022. i
thought we were past it the biggest
hurdle this movie has to overcome is the
fact that it just feels
20 years behind the times it feels 20
years too late it does feel like this
aggregate like someone sat down was like
hey it'd be cool if we had jason bourne
action movie in a mission impossible
type setting with a new crew a little
bit of ocean's 11 thrown in there
because it has the flavor of that too
and if it was this jason bourne ocean's
11 mission impossible movie that came
out when ocean's 11 and jason bourne
came out and jason board's born identity
you know what i mean it'd feel like this
cool hybrid of the two like someone saw
both the movies was like oh hey let's
fuse them great feels new feels like the
marriage of cinema i've wanted for the
past year and a half because it's the
early 2000s but in 2022 this movie just
feels like it's late to the action movie
spy thriller party i don't know the
story of production for this movie but
if i found out that the 355 was written
back in the early 2000s and was just
sitting on a shelf and got dusted off
recently and they decided to make it
into a movie finally i wouldn't be
surprised not at all and that out of
date at the very least late to the party
feeling has to do with some of the plot
twists too there's some plot twists in
here like didn't see that coming digits
like i did because i've seen these
movies since you know the 80s 90s 2000s
to now yeah it might have been
mind-blowing back in 1987. it's just not
in 2022. i didn't hate the movie like i
walked out of the movie going the movie
was fine it was okay it was it was fine
but there are so many spy thriller
movies espionage movies heist movies out
there that are so much more than just
fine 24 hours in a day this movie's two
hours long which it feels a bit longer
than that like it didn't at a point i
was like this movie has really good
pacing because i thought we were in the
third act and it was just like oh it's
not ending it's still going
it's still going
it's still ending yeah you know that
movie has great time management thing i
was just thinking i take it back but a
two hour movie is one twelfth of your
day am i gonna be like hey you should
watch this movie you should take up
one-twelfth of your day on this movie i
can't do that movies like this happen
every year at the end of the year in
december when i'm making my top 10 best
top 10 worst list i'm scrolling through
my reviews seeing what i reviewed i'll
run across my review the 355 and it'll
be like oh wow
totally forgot about that movie would
have been better suited to come out in
2003-ish but for 2022 i'm just not gonna
remember the movie in t-minus one day
yeah wait what are we talking about all
right so the three five five have you
seen it what did you think about it did
you forget that it was even coming out
did you know it was out right now or
what's your favorite espionage and or
spy thriller whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you